the end of the day you don't necessarily
need a choice of 23 underarm spray do
hearts or of 18 different pairs of
sneakers when children are hungry in
this country every day in this country
thousands of children go hungry because
of too many deodorant choices this is
Hannah Hannah wasn't always hungry until
the day Old Spice released his redzone
opera reefs when defense solid and now
she's starving at the Bernie Sanders
Save the Children fund we worked
tirelessly to remove such choices from
the marketplace so we can feed every
child in America economics say if you
have any other kinds I'm actually
allergic are you in the 1% yes the 1% of
people fatally allergic to aluminum just
another bourgeois fan Kent call the
Bernie Sanders Save the Children fund
and we'll even include a photo of a
special child your donation is helping
of course it's the same child in every
photo because why choices and if you
call in the next ten minutes we'll even
include admission to the Bernie Sanders
School of Economics where tuition is
free and yet overpriced
the Bernie Sanders Save the Children
fund call today
you